sony scotty opponents would have parts parts
from the usa is obviously tired tired
against slowly it can get exciting
yes I'm all with
it it's true we won't get three I'll get
it much more often otherwise I
'll go
back to the solar position  where i
'm just wondering i've just had
more than one party with de to find out
if maybe the four is an idea
or if that's absurd can both can
letter his springer i had 5 at the time
but he probably
didn't have around 10 well better not
106 I can probably do it
again even though springer b
I don't know
so well I'd rather go back like this
but now
I thought he had to look somehow because it's difficult like
four times if that's a
problem maybe that's
bad too, totally  can be ridiculous
but
probably with it like it used to be very
simple
the whole action didn't achieve
anything let's do development again
how do you play it  now so important
well you could try
taking acts of violence on f3 and playing the four
but it works early on
so
bell g5 it makes me uncomfortable to
create
but i also have to
watch out for springer the films on the unmasking
i was a bit too
pseudo active
here it runs anyway  serve
i think he has to play the 1
so i expect the move as usual was
the expectation when i thought bishop e6
would be a bit stupid if he
drugged the four but he
probably even has jumper g5
on it too there that was probably
one  pretty stupid idea player how
much to draw
i could but runs easily play five
and follower
follower c2 nerves
maybe it was a good idea after all
knight the four maybe interesting
here
what that covers i could take the four if i
capture b4
could be an idea too  seen
so i don't know how to assess that yet
the four damme runners c3
bcr are
difficult to sa  gen
i can somehow play tempo differently
with maybe wins bad wins
these are
tempo runs 46 win bad tempo
and mood
but above all i shouldn't
fall asleep
so
if i move away from here now says well
i think i just have to see
that i get here as soon
as possible  fast the game here so
positionally fast so don't
dawdle in any way
yes it may be that i'm also in a really
bad position
c4 i haven't really
had the calculation
be it right now or
maybe later
he could also just be here
that seems slow
can i use it
ok would you like to play comfortably so
to say
ok
let's see if we can attack something here with the area
it's
definitely not dangerous dhabi 7 of course now
the people are just totally greedy
i'll take them  every [ __ ] gone well now
probably also done so if I
do now  nh 6 games what does he pull then
it
goes by like this 3 my god i'm so slow
i'm so slow always that i ca
n't play this position
properly i think it wasn't that
bad
here i don't think what you
're doing here
now I don't have a move and I
just don't have anything on the clock [ __ ] so
that can be answered very coolly with king heinz
yes played stupid just played stupid
let's show us how it
would have been played correctly
thoma 6 wins yes that
doesn't surprise me spin ac3  yes, yes
left out